- Good morning, everyone.
Thank you for joining me
as I talk to you about
seamless network-based
fraud protection in FinTech
and digital business.
I'm Oscar Rodriguez,
Senior Director, Global
Partner Solutions at Vonage,
and today, we're gonna look
at how the mobile network
can help stop fraud before it
ever reaches your business.
Now, FinTech and digital platforms
are under constant pressure
to balance security
with user experience,
and attackers are getting faster, cheaper,
and more automated.
Now, I'll walk you through how
network-based intelligence,
Silent Authentication,
and branded communication,
can create a seamless layer of protection
that improves trust,
strengthens conversions,
and lowers cost.
So let's jump in.
First of all, let me take
a moment to ground us
into who Vonage is today
as part of Ericsson.
So we are an end-to-end
communications provider
that serves more than
100,000 enterprise customers
across more than a hundred countries.
Our platform supports
over 1.7 million registered developers
and is powered by a global
team of over 2,500 employees,
including over 900 in
product and technology.
On the left side, you
can see the full suite
that makes this possible.
We combined unified communications,
contact center capabilities,
and our full range of communication APIs
covering voice, video,
messaging, and social channels.
Then on the the right half of the wheel,
you'll see the next generation
of network-powered solutions.
This includes mobile
identity tools like Verify
with Silent Authentication
and Identity Insights,
Fraud Defender services,
and new capabilities for
location, network insights,
and connectivity experience.
Together, this creates
a complete ecosystem
that lets businesses engage, authenticate,
and protect their customers
using both traditional channels
and intelligence from the mobile network.
It is the foundation that enables
everything we are talking about today,
especially the next
wave of fraud prevention
powered by network APIs.
So one of the problems
that we're seeing now
is that fraud is no longer
a manual one-off effort.
It has become productized.
Entire attack chains are
packaged as easy to use services
that anyone can buy.
Criminals no longer need technical skills.
They can subscribe to a
$5 voice cloning SaaS,
spin up a drag and drop phishing kit
with built-in support, by the way,
or even purchase SIM swap as a service.
Now these tools make it simple
to launch attacks at a massive scale.
And the cost to run these
attacks has collapsed as well.
What used to take time,
skill, and resources,
can now be executed for just cents.
AI and automation are
doing the heavy lifting,
which means more attacks launch
faster and by more people.
Now the barrier to entry
has never been lower.
What once required a sophisticated hacker,
can now be done by a script
kitty with a credit card.
This is why defenses need to evolve.
Fraud has become industrial,
and our protection strategy has
to match that level of scale
and automation.
Now you should know that fraud
is exploding across every channel.
The average data breach
now costs $4.4 million,
and nearly one in four US adults
have experienced some
type of account takeover
or fraud just last year.
Anybody in the audience
experienced any type of
account fraud or takeover?
No? Maybe you know somebody that has?
There you go.
So, you're not alone.
Even the most secure of
organizations get hit.
In fact, in January 2024,
the SEC's official Twitter
account was hacked.
A single fake post about
Bitcoin ETF approval
sent market surging before
the breach was confirmed.
So what does that tell us?
If the SEC can be compromised, anyone can.
Now, the SEC hack wasn't
a technical exploit.
It was done through social engineering.
And this is the same pattern
we see across industries.
That's where fraudsters
pretend to be customers
or employees.
They use SIM swaps to take over numbers,
phish for credentials,
and spam users with multifactor prompts
until somebody finally gives in.
All of these start with one weak link.
Anybody guess what that weak link is?
(audience faintly speaking)
What's that?
You're getting close.
It's the phone number.
Everybody has a mobile device
that has a phone number attached to it,
even a wearable, that has a
phone number attached to it.
We rely on it for many things.
So, let's imagine in a
contact center scenario,
an agent gets a call,
the phone number
presented in the caller ID
matches that of a customer record.
The name provided by the caller
also matches that customer record.
But in reality,
the caller is a hacker or fraudster
that took over that SIM an hour ago.
Now, without trust signals,
which Vonage can provide,
the agent might help reset the account
or approve a large transfer
in a banking scenario
which could drain somebody's life savings,
ruining lives, and of
course, brand reputation.
Now every incident like this
erodes trust and brand loyalty.
And since 70% of breaches
start with social engineering,
prevention must happen in real-time.
Now on this slide, we're
introducing the idea
that next generation fraud
protection is now possible
because it taps directly
into the mobile network.
This gives businesses a way to stop fraud
before it ever reaches their systems,
and it does this without slowing down
or inconveniencing legitimate users.
The mobile network quietly verifies
who is on the other end of a phone number.
It confirms that the device is real,
that the subscriber is authentic,
and that nothing suspicious is
happening behind the scenes.
So during an account creation, login,
or high value actions,
like large transfers,
real customers move
through with no extra steps
because the checks are happening invisibly
in the background.
Now this same intelligence can block
a wide range of threats in real-time.
Fake accounts, account takeovers,
refund abuse, social engineering attempts,
phishing, and smishing,
even traffic pumping,
all become detectable
because the network can see signals
that apps and browsers
alone simply cannot.
If something looks off, it is flagged,
and before it even becomes a fraud
and if everything checks out,
well, the user continues
without any friction.
Now this creates a protection layer
that sits under your
business and your customers.
It is always on
and it'll always verifying.
Customers never notice it,
but it is constantly shielding them
from account and communications fraud.
It reinforces the entire
fraud prevention stack
while keeping every trusted
interaction smooth and seamless.
Now, when you look at the
full customer journey,
fraud is not isolated to just one stage.
It can show up anywhere.
From the moment the user first signs up,
to the interactions they have
months or even years later.
What is powerful about the
mobile network intelligence
is that it gives you
protection at every point
without changing the customer experience.
At the very beginning,
during account creation,
the mobile network can confirm
that the person actually
possesses the phone number
that they are using.
This happens instantly and invisibly
using silent authentication.
And it helps prevent fake or
automated account creation
without forcing the user through
extra verification steps.
Now, when the user logs in
or performs any sensitive action,
the network can silently verify
that the device and subscriber
match what you would expect.
If someone has hijacked an account
or is trying to break in,
well then, the access can
be blocked right away.
Now, during account recovery,
which is one of the biggest
points of vulnerability,
the network can detect SIM swap activity.
And since SIM swaps are often
used as a precursor to fraud,
catching that signal early,
protects both the user and the business
during the reset process.
Now, even in day-to-day interactions
like customer service
calls or outbound outreach,
the network adds trust.
Branded calls and messages
ensure that the customer knows
the communication is legitimate,
which helps eliminate spoofing
and impersonation attempts.
So across onboarding, authentication,
recovery, and engagement,
the mobile network acts as a continuous
and invisible shield.
It strengthens security at every step
while keeping the experience simple
and smooth for real customers.
The Vonage Protection Suite
is our umbrella set of a
capabilities for mobile identity
and fraud prevention,
all powered by the intelligence
of the mobile network.
Now the first piece is our Verify API
with Silent Authentication.
This is our network-powered
two-factor authentication solution.
It confirms possession of the phone number
directly with the mobile network,
which makes it harder to spoof
and far more reliable than
traditional SMS-based OTPs.
Next is our Identity
Insights API with SIM swap.
This brings network level intelligence
into your fraud and risk models.
It gives you real-time signals
about the status of the
device and subscriber,
helping you strengthen decisions
around onboarding, login,
and high-value actions.
Remember our earlier example
where the agent could have
approved a large transfer?
If he had known that the SIM was swapped,
he would've blocked that.
Then we have branded communication.
This allows businesses
to send trusted branded messages and calls
that are hard to spoof.
It helps customers know
that the message or
call they are receiving
is truly coming from you, the brand,
which reduces scams and
social engineering attempts.
Now together, these solutions form
a comprehensive protection layer
that helps secure accounts,
reduce fraud, and build trust
across every customer interaction.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
switch over to a quick demo.
So let me walk you
through this short demo.
So notice the...
For this particular request,
we're using our Identity Insights API.
Now, the payload in this case includes
insights for format, SIM
swap, subscriber match...
I'm sorry, SIM swap and
current and original carrier,
all of which are now generally available
for all US major carriers through Vonage.
Location verification, subscriber match,
roaming, and reachability insights
are planned in future releases.
So as you can see,
current carrier gives us the type of line.
In this case, it's a mobile line.
We're using this UK number
being a mobile line.
So it means that we can
get additional insights
on that phone number from the network.
Next is format.
The Format Insight tells us
the country the number belongs to
including the country code
and regional time zones,
and of course, country-specific
formatting as well.
As an example, in North America,
we use parentheses around the area code.
Next, we have original carrier.
Original carrier, it differs
from the current carrier.
From that, you can derive
that the number was ported.
And if it was ported and you combine that
with a SIM swap signal,
well, that can be some type of clue
that there might be some
type of account takeover.
SIM swap not only tells
us if the SIM was swapped,
but it will also give us a timestamp
of when it was swapped last.
And you can actually include
a parameter in the request
indicating a period that you wanna check.
So if you wanted to check the last hour
up to the last 100 days to
see if a SIM was swapped
within that period of time.
For subscriber match,
you basically provide us any
information that you have
on this particular user and phone number.
So if you have their name, for example,
a date of birth, and even an address,
we'll go ahead and check that
with the mobile network records,
and we'll provide you
with a match on that.
In this case, you could see
that the first name, last name match,
and then looks like
we've moved on past that.
Sorry about...
So, you might've noticed
that the first name and
last name matched exactly.
The date of birth, there
was a partial match.
For location verification,
this allows us to check
if the device associated
with the phone number
is within a certain radius of location,
such as where a transaction
or a login attempt
is expected to take place.
And then roaming will
return true or false,
just depending if the user is roaming,
and also return where the user
is running, which country.
And then reachability
will determine if the device
is connected to the network
through SMS or a data channel.
All right, so that was a very simple demo
of our Identity Insights API.
Very simple.
It's a quick API that takes
milliseconds to execute,
but really, it could save,
would I say $4.4 million,
the average data breach cost,
for an API call that cost just cents.
All right, so let me finish
with a real-world example
of silent authentication at scale.
So Lydia,
is one of Europe's
fastest growing neobanks,
serving more than 8 million users.
They were looking for a
way to strengthen security
without slowing anyone down.
So they moved to Vonage Verify
and Silent Authentication.
Now the impact was immediate.
Authentication times dropped by 50%,
giving users a faster and
smoother login experience.
Now, when Silent Authentication is used,
they also eliminated
SMS-based social
engineering attacks entirely
because Silent Auth removes
the need for one-time codes
that can be intercepted or phished.
And on top of that,
they were able to lower
their total cost of ownership
compared to their previous solution,
since Silent Auth reduces reliance on SMS
while improving conversion rates.
This is a great example
of how network-powered
authentication can protect users,
improve performance,
and optimize cost all at the same time.
That has been my presentation.
Thank you for your time.
If you wanna book a meeting
with me, scan the QR code,
connect with me on LinkedIn,
or reach me out on the show floor.
Thank you very much, everyone.